[Music]
but actually slowly comes in and lands
their headshot now navera swings into
action there's three
and four panning the stats could be on
franco
finishes it off with a beautiful one tap
navera
had a legacy to live up to scream's
shadow loomed over his career
even if i win a wedger it will not be
enough you know
my brother did a lot of things he loses
just a little bit of health
bond planted in the nick of time and
zanterra's
knowing navera is hot on his heels post
up on the flat
oh shut up what but just as navera was
coming into his own
valve got in his way to make it work on
the long term it's really really hard so
yeah doing it uh
we thought about doing it but i felt
that it was impossible
like in my head i was like i will just
play my game i will just
give everything i stay focused on the
game i need a frag out here
and he has found flamie boomitch with
the bomb on his back up high can't hit
the flick down to 48 electronic mollies
running out of safe haven jiggles and
fit hits the shot as well go on navira
he saves them with a triple kill oh
tough
what a play by novara yeah walks in
gonna make sure they don't even have a
damn
chance four kills for navera off the off
he knows how hot those shots really were
if you haven't heard of navera you've
probably heard of his older brother
because nivera grew up in the shadow of
one of the most mechanically talented cs
go players of
all time scream all right it's their
t-side where they really struggle
i have one more flash two more bananas
flashing
so [ __ ] easy man the one for sure
yeah he's got one bullet in it he's
three legs got one bullet oh
scream
scream makes me scream see navera is
scream's younger brother and
he spent most of his life watching from
behind screams shoulders worried that
he'd never make it out of his older
brother's shadow
even if i win a ranger it will not be
enough you know
my brother did a lot of things in this
game and
i have to work hard like really really
hard because
yeah he's such a big player
yeah i'm a fan of my brother himself you
know
but scream cs career faded from glory a
long time ago
between losses piling up strained
relationships and in-game blunders
scream's reputation isn't what it once
was the head shot machine has since
departed cs go for valorant and he's
flourished there it seems like the game
is made
holy [ __ ] man but navera was committed
to cs go and while his older brother's
shadow loomed large
over him he was ready to make a name for
himself
but actually slowly comes in and lands
the headshot now neverend springs into
action that's three
and four panning the stats could be on
franco
finishes it off with a beautiful one tap
navera was
popping off and big names we're starting
to notice
french cs icons like apex shocks and rpk
guys who had spent years playing with
scream were watching the vera closely
and soon
it was official nivera joined vitality
france's top cs org as a sixth man
but he still had a lot to live up to
it's been the storyline of the day are
we going to see those mid-match
substitutions coming out from vitality
and indeed
we are misuta it's gonna be coming out
nivera is going
to be coming in next for dusty now
teams like astralis and na'vi had
already been experimenting with larger
rosters to give their core players much
needed breaks
but vitality took the six-man concept to
a whole new level
you see nivera masuta and shocks would
all be swapping in and out during the
same series depending on what map they
were playing in
and no major team had done this before
they were pushing boundaries that no one
had pushed
so when dust 2 or inferno rolled around
it was navera's time to shine
oh tough what a play by novara yeah
walks in
gonna make sure they don't even have a
damn chance four kills for navera off
the off he knows how hot those shots
really were
yeah even if he dies he's just he's
basically won the round
tabson and keto would fall easily navera
he's looking for him
here's the movement coming in they're
gonna just try and push past two backs
for navera nine kills on him 11 rounds
for vitality
they are looking for the back-to-back
16-1 he loses just a little bit of
health
bond pointed in the nick of time and
zenteres
knowing the vera is hot on his heels
posts up on the flat
oh shut up what when hltv
asked him about how he felt about having
such a limited role in the team he said
as long as we win that's all that
matters to me i don't care about being a
star or whatever
i just want to win with the team and the
rest will come on its own
navera was finally stepping out of his
brother's long shadow he had
solid results against top teams
including wins against astralis and
na'vi
two of the best teams in the world time
ticking quick the op shot draws his
attention and zewu takes the kill
vitality ladies and gentlemen are your
blast
fall finals champions
[Music]
what by allowing navera to focus on what
he did
best and also giving shocks and masuta
the occasional break
vitality developed an edge like in my
head i was like i will just play my game
i will just give everything i stay
focused on the game and
like it's not like i don't care but i
don't mind of losing or
just give my best i give everything for
the team but not everybody supported
this new formula
particularly valve in their 2021
regional major rankings
update valve announced that teams would
be penalized 20
of their points every time they changed
their lineup prior to or
during an rmr event and since rmr points
determine who gets to play in the next
major
having a substitute just isn't worth it
anymore any competitive advantages you
get by fielding a sixth man
don't make up for the fact that you're
going to miss the biggest cs tournament
of the year
as a result vitality benched nivera and
announced he was stepping down from
active player status if he wanted to be
on the top 10 or something
he could work on the long term maybe but
on this one
to make it work on the long term it's
really really hard so
yeah he doing it uh
we thought about doing it but i felt
that was impossible and
obviously that's not my decision that
was vitality and
the staff decision but yeah the the word
from bob was
was hard to to handle for us and just to
continue
in his own statement navera tweeted i'm
motivated i'm open to a loan or transfer
there's still some debate as to whether
or not vitality made the right choice by
benching the vera
after all he was the full package navera
can op he can
rifle he's clutch under pressure and his
stats aren't that bad either he even
managed to come close to the top of
player ratings for iem beijing
only coming behind zawu and simple
they've actually done the same though
they've
invested horses into zywoo that's novera
i need a frag out here and he has found
flamey boomick with the bomb on his back
up high can't hit the flick down to 48
electronic mollies
running out of safe haven jiggles and
fit hits the shot as well go on navira
he saves them with a triple kill the
only question now is
where does nivera go from here kuben
from madeline's had some thoughts on
hltv confirmed if you look for pros of
of this situation like
he has improved they have developed him
like they have
really good coaching stuff behind i'm
not sure if he's over 20 i doubt it
uh so in my opinion they can they can
still put him on the bench
and i'm pretty sure some of really good
teams
can come and and ask ask for a buy and
like
in such a short time they have developed
the young player
while six-man rosters might be gone for
now navera's future
is still bright he's more than just
scream's little brother he's not just
the baby aim god anymore
he's his own player an up-and-coming
superstar in his own right
who might just be the next generation of
cs go
more listen i'm all for real names in
esports personally but i feel like more
esports players should name themselves
after jojo characters
imagine if like in our world champion
cream starter
the new starting the new starting top
laner for t1 hot pants
would be amazing everyone should name
themselves your jojo characters so they
say
misuta okay i'll say mr